good morning everyone today I'm going to
talk to you about fold and this is a
project that I worked on in Ethan's
future news class with Kevin who who is
a student in that mighty Media Lab group
called macro connections so they do a
lot of work with creating interactive
visualizations for complex datasets so
Kevin and I work together on this
project and we're pushing it forward
beyond the class I wanted to tell you
guys about it so Kevin and I like to
consider ourselves news junkies but we
got to talking and realized there's lots
of kind of stories we avoid reading
because we lack the background to
understand them and we figure we're not
the only ones with this problem so I
mean imagine reading about the 2008
housing crisis without knowing what a
mortgage is or the 2014 crimean crisis
without knowing where crimea is or even
the discovery of Higgs boson without
knowing who this Higgs boson guy even is
so I mean there's lots of places you can
go to try and find this background
information but chances are you'll
either get lost
very soon after starting read to read it
and just close that tab never to return
or you'll start clicking links and get
lost very quickly very far away from the
story you started with so whether the
context is definitional historical or
technical if you lack it you feel stupid
and you might just disengage with the
story altogether which we is a problem
that we want it to solve so we've become
obsessed with this question how do you
tell a complex story so my background is
in human centered design and interaction
design so I like to think about how to
build products that people actually want
to use that speak to their human
motivations and desires and Kevin as I
mentioned his background is in data
visualization so he likes to think about
how to use the limited real estate of
your screen to convey the most
information and the information that's
important to you so fold where is we
considered a new way to tell stories by
combining context with structure so for
readers that looks like a vertical axis
for scaffolding and chunking a story and
each portion of vertical axis has a
horizontal axis that provides some
context provided by the storyteller
which may be a journalist or maybe
somebody just a blogger or any other
kind of storyteller and for for
storytellers that provides a modular
that's appropriate for some kinds of
stories particularly chronological
event-driven or stories that might
require a lot of multimedia content to
really understand so I don't have time
to go through the live demo with you
today but if you want to see it I can
show you afterwards but this is just
what the authoring platform looks like
and each piece of this is editable so
you can click right into the title and
start typing your content there so the
the white blocks if you click on the
plus sign here you can add new elements
to the chronological story and then the
plus button here in gray you can add new
context elements to that bar right there
so that might be photo or an animated
gif or a YouTube video audio or a map
and these are here's a story that
someone has written as written a little
bit so the left and right hand buttons
on the top allow the reader to scroll
through that context bar and there's the
context bar associated with each block
of the story so Kevin I've been thinking
a lot about how to scaffold context
creation because we recognize that
storytellers have the best of intentions
to educate their readership but it's
often they may not have the time to do
so so we're trying to think of ways to
pull from sources of content and context
that exists elsewhere so the YouTube API
and other other services so our mission
is twofold
I can't help but make that joke every
time when I hope storytellers make their
work more accessible to a general
audience and we want to help readers
better understand a story they might
otherwise have disengaged with because
it made them feel stupid so we're hoping
to launch for open beta at the end of
summer and we would love it if lots of
you folks in this room would be
interested in participating and checking
it out so if you're interested head to
fold media MIT edu to sign up for our
mailing list so we can let you know when
we launch or come find me sometime today
and I'd love to talk about any of these
ideas Thanks
[Applause]